(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
(slow country music)
♪ It was right after senior year ♪
♪ Just before the summer disappeared ♪
♪ We went ridin' in them old farm ruts ♪
♪ Hangin' out on the gate of his truck ♪
♪ We threw a blanket 'neath the sunset ♪
♪ Bein' brave as 18 gets ♪
♪ We gave each other
more than our hearts ♪
♪ With the help of a mason jar ♪
♪ Drinkin' watermelon moonshine ♪
♪ We cut the burn with a little lime ♪
♪ Parkin' back in them kudzu vines ♪
♪ I was his and every bit
of that boy was mine ♪
♪ Too young to know what love was ♪
♪ But we were learnin' on a sweet buzz ♪
♪ There's never nothin'
like the first time ♪
♪ And mine's always gonna taste like ♪
♪ Watermelon moonshine ♪
♪ I thought that high would last forever ♪
♪ But that ain't what it does ♪
♪ Maybe we were drunk in love ♪
♪ Or maybe we were just ♪
♪ Drinkin' watermelon moonshine ♪
♪ Cut the burn with a little lime ♪
♪ Parkin' back in them kudzu vines ♪
♪ I was his and every bit
of that boy was mine ♪
♪ Too young to know what love was ♪
♪ But we were learnin' on a sweet buzz ♪
♪ There's never nothin'
like the first time ♪
♪ And mine's always gonna taste like ♪
♪ Watermelon moonshine ♪
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)